israelis have been going through a
two-year cycle
of election government formation
collapse
and repeat in this fourth cycle there is
little suspense
prime minister benjamin netanyahu and
his likud party
are expected to get the most votes even
though more than half of israelis
recently polled
want him out you are not looking for
your ideology you are voting
against someone so it's very hard to
to build a country like this you know
you cannot vote because you don't want
someone
you have to vote because you want
something happen and that's the problem
netanyahu needs to get 61 seats in the
knesset to form a government
no one ever has so the question is
who would he form a coalition government
with
he's alienated former allies and is
facing stiff competition
from within the right i think he's been
a wonderful politician for israel in the
past he's been in power way too long
and he has too many issues surrounding
him at this point
i'd really like to see a change and it
surprises me that
the whole country isn't behind that idea
janet melzer is a liberal voter who like
many others believes israelis have a
fifth election
on the horizon really concerned where
the direction the country is going
lack of respect for the other total lack
of respect for the other
no understanding of civil rights or
democracy
voter participation in the previous
election was 71 percent
pollsters predict a lower turnout for
now
israelis vote and wait to see if their
country can move past
this unprecedented political limbo
let's take a look at the main candidates
in the fray netanyahu
is head of the likud party but he's also
on trial for corruption
he is hoping his efforts to get people
vaccinated quickly against covert 19 and
the normalization of ties with some
arab countries will keep him in the lead
his former chief of staff naftali
bennett and head of the right-wing
yamina party has criticized the prime
minister's handling of the pandemic
but he has then ruled out joining a
liquid-led government
after the election another right-wing
challenger is gideon tsar
he's the leader of the new hope party
which supports settlement construction
in the occupied west bank
and opposes the iran nuclear deal
his political agenda is similar to
netanyahu's but he's
not interested in a coalition
partnership
and finally there's tv host turned
politician yeah lapid he heads the
opposition centrist
yesh ati party he is considered one of
the strongest candidates
and was once a coalition partner in a
netanyahu-led government
back in 2013. let's go to dalia
schindlin who is a public opinion
strategist she joins us from tel aviv
many thanks for speaking to us dalian on
al jazeera
now prime minister benjamin netanyahu is
hoping that the country's fast vaccine
rollout will push him into a stable
majority
but not everyone is convinced about how
he's handled that corona virus pandemic
are they
no in fact the vaccination rollout as
successful as it has been
is only the most recent thing to happen
in a year of
his trying to manage the pandemic in
ways that have drawn
a lot of fire including from some of his
own
supporter constituencies but i have to
say that for the most part
it seems like the majority of voters are
filtering
their assessment of netanyahu's handling
of the pandemic through
their pre-existing views of him as prime
minister
so there's plenty of criticism of him
from those who want
uh you know a government that does not
include the ultra-orthodox parties who
uh support a more liberal approach to
israeli society and they think that he
has given in
too much to the ultra-orthodox
communities uh in
imposing sweeping lockdown measures
presumably for political reasons even
though the ultra-orthodox community had
much higher rates
of infection through covet that is the
main point of contention
over his handling of the pandemic and
those people have not changed their
minds in being angry at him
because of the vaccination rollout even
though they give him credit for it
naturally of course his supporters give
him lots of credit for the vaccination
roll out but they were already
supporting him
indeed picking up on that point is it
not extraordinary that people's minds
are so little change when it comes to
uh uh president uh prime minister
netanyahu i mean it's
it's remarkable he's be he's on trial on
charges of bribery fraud breach of trust
but still he he remains where he is in
terms of his popularity
his staying power is quite remarkable
i've worked as a strategist
on eight national campaigns in israel
and in about 15 other countries and it
is
unusual to see an incumbent in power
for 12 years consecutively a total of 15
years and his
uh his standing in israeli society such
as it is
in the sense that about 25 to 29 percent
of the voters have supported him in
recent elections is really quite
uh impressive as a political feat
however it's not terribly surprising
because we've had three elections in
very quick succession
and all of the factors that we're
talking about save for the covet
management which is a brand new issue
they were all in place even ahead of the
april 2019 elections
the investigations against netanyahu
were known it was clear that he would be
indicted and in the course of
2019 and 20 he was indicted and his
trial started but voters knew all of
that even going into the april 2019
election so it's not that surprising
that they haven't changed their minds
one way or another about whether they
support or oppose him
but this time as you correctly pointed
out a majority of israelis do
prefer that he not continue being prime
minister but because of our coalition
system
he may very well be sorry to interrupt
you this time round he does
face new challenges from right wing uh
contenders as well
how is that likely to play uh into any
election result
well it does seem like he has lost votes
if you look at the average of all the
surveys and the general trend in the
many many many surveys israel uh
israeli media have conducted during this
campaign he
he has 36 seats in the outgoing
parliament uh that is out of 120 making
him the biggest party
but in all surveys and in all averages
of all surveys he is not getting any
higher than 32
but in most surveys he is reaching
between 28 and 30 seats
now there could be many reasons for that
decline and we also might see
additional support for likud on election
day tonight
when the polls come out when the exit
polls come out which is something that's
happened in the past but it doesn't look
like he's going
to be able to repeat 36 seats and so
to some extent that is partly because of
these right-wing challengers but to be
honest
the right-wing challengers haven't done
all that well because he's still
you know in top place by double digits
both in both in terms of the number of
seats
he's getting in in knesset in the
parliament and
leading in terms of the percentage of
israelis who vote for him towering
over those right-wing challengers each
of them naftali bennett and
are barely getting between eight and ten
percent of the vote
and so they have sort of created an
alternative but
there is uh just a stalwart base of
support for likud and netanyahu
and i think that giron tsar looks like
he's
uh on the path that moshe khachlon took
just in the 2015 elections not that long
ago also trying to create a liquid
breakaway
also won 10 seats but then couldn't
survive politically and his party no
longer exists
really interesting to get your thoughts
dahlia shin lin public opinion
strategist speaking to us there
from tel aviv well we can turn to our
correspondent natasha ghonim who is live
for us in tel aviv
as well natasha you're out on the
streets what is the mood out there
voters what kind of turnout are we
seeing
well we're in tel aviv as you mentioned
and turnout is 10
lower than it was during the previous
election cycle at this point in time
if you look behind me there is a big
sign here that says march
23rd all of us it's in our hands
obviously an attempt to try to boost
voter turnout for people who may have
election fatigue after now having to be
been asked to vote for a fourth time in
two years
we spoke to voters in jerusalem earlier
in the day
and again this all boils down to a
referendum
on prime minister benjamin netanyahu
for those who are supporting netanyahu
they're probably
in good spirits because it's expected
that the status quo
will remain at the end of the night and
by that i mean
that right now netanyahu's likud party
is still expected
to be the largest vote getter not enough
to reach the threshold of a 61 seat um
in the knesset which is needed to form a
government
but still enough that from there
netanyahu would be expected to do what
he's attempted to do
three previous times and that is to form
a coalition government
for those who oppose netanyahu who say
he's been in office too long
who have told us that they believe that
the corruption trial
that he is facing it resumes next month
he is facing
a fraud breach of trust and bribery
charges
they say that they feel very hopeless
they feel that
they don't understand why despite more
than 50 percent of israelis who are
recently who were recently polled
saying they want netanyahu out why it
seems like the political limbo
will remain in israel nonetheless
they did come out and vote and it'll be
interesting to see
if voter turnout is high a veteran
pollster said
that he did not expect voter turnout
especially due to the pandemic
and perhaps due to election fatigue to
be as high as it was
in the previous round of elections that
was 71 percent
natasha kaneem there for us in tel aviv
many thanks